it is official have you heard it's
finally official the us government is
determined
that president-elect o'biden is a quote
apparent winner of the election which
means
the transition process can formally
begin now you know it comes more than
two weeks after it became clear
that joe biden would be our next
president president trump tweeted that
he made the approval
in the best interests of our country but
later he tweeted he would never
actually concede that he lost paula reed
is at the white house paula good morning
good morning anthony even as president
trump says he will not concede
this is what the biden harris transition
team has been waiting for
this is a letter from the general
services administration telling them
that now resources and services will be
available so the transition
can finally get underway after weeks of
delay
gsa administrator emily murphy
officially authorized the initial steps
to transfer control of the federal
government
among the resources now available to the
biden team
will be 6.3 million dollars in
congressionally appropriated funds
along with 175 thousand square feet of
federal
office space including secure facilities
for sensitive intelligence briefings
in a letter to president-elect biden
murphy wrote she was never
directly or indirectly pressured by the
white house to delay the process
in response to the news mr biden's
transition team wrote
it will soon gain complete understanding
of the trump administration's efforts to
hollow out government agencies
this also means the biden team will be
able to communicate with trump officials
about the covid vaccine plan which mr
biden has called crucial
more people may die if we don't
coordinate
while the president initially said he
recommended the transition process begin
he also said his case against the
election results
strongly continues and i believe we will
prevail
he later tweeted that he would never
concede
but the trump campaign has had dozens of
legal losses
including one on monday when the
pennsylvania supreme court rejected its
efforts to block the state from counting
certain absentee ballots
that decision clears the way for votes
to be certified in several
counties also on monday
michigan's board of canvassers voted to
certify the state's election results
paving mr biden's way to the state's 16
electoral votes
and almost certainly blocking any
pathway for president trump to overturn
the election outcome one of the board's
two republicans
joined its democratic members to certify
the results
in this case the law is absolutely clear
we have a clear legal duty to certify
the result of the election as shown by
the returns
that were given to us in recent days
we've seen more and more republicans
break with the president and pressure
the administration
to recognize president-elect biden as
the winner
and one of those lawmakers senator lamar
alexander
he encouraged the president to take
pride in his considerable
accomplishments
and put the country first tony
paula thank you very much